by the way one of the top priorities for
the radical left is to do absolutely
nothing about the looming crisis at our
southern border they don't care about
the death destruction and devastation
caused by our porous open border they
don't care about the thousands of
migrants making the perilous journey
north they just want to deny president
trump yet another accomplishment take a
look I can tell you the Republicans want
to have a wall but the Democrats are
told that you can't do that they are
doing a tremendous disservice the
Democrats are doing a tremendous
disservice to our country I don't think
Nancy has it too
and I see that when she says wolves are
immoral
she doesn't have she doesn't know and
and I wish he did because she's hurting
this country so badly joining us now is
freedom caucus chairman mark meadows and
the author of the Russia hoax Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett all right
congressman meadows you know I heard
something interesting and that is that
there is talk of biometrically tagging
some of these illegals sent and if they
send them back if they come back then
they face some serious penalties are you
familiar with that concept at all well
that's part of that smart technology
that a lot of our Democrats have been
talking about but really the problem
what we have judge is this is not only
do they come back but they come back
over and over and over again because we
don't have a border wall or barrier at
our southern border and so listen part
of the smart technology is certainly
part of the solution but I can tell you
the bigger problem right now is that we
have a bicameral bipartisan conference
that supposedly has been meeting and
they've only met one time in the last
week they're not even here in Washington
DC and they're supposedly coming up with
solutions they're not serious about
negotiating all right so they have three
weeks the president said look I'm giving
you three weeks guys go in there and
hammer something out you know bipartisan
both houses and you're telling me they
met once and now they're gone again yeah
they've only met one time
they met Wednesday they don't have any
scheduled meetings to meet again until
possibly at the earliest next Wednesday
so it's not really serious about coming
up to a solution and I can tell you when
the Democrats rolled out their first
offer it has zero money for border wall
and I mean you know at this point you
have to wonder if they ever had an
intention of negotiating in the first
place you know what I don't know who's
on this committee but I'm gonna find out
I'm gonna talk about it on my show
tomorrow night cuz you know what do you
meet once when you've got three weeks to
resolve one of the most important issues
in our country right now you plan on
meeting once next week that's an outrage
but I'm gonna go to Greg Jarrett all
right Greg
the president says there's a good chance
and based on what we just heard from
congressman mark meadows if they don't
come up with something Congress has not
wanted to come up with something since
1986 they don't come up with anything
the president has the right to declare
an emergency correctos under the
national emergencies act of 1976
Congress actually delegated unfettered
authority and discretion to the
president they can whine all they want
but they're the ones who gave him that
power once he invokes it he then turns
to another law that Congress passed six
years after that in 1982 which says
specifically he is authorized to
undertake military construction projects
not otherwise authorized by Congress so
they they gave him another tool that he
can utilize they can complain all they
want they can sue in the end they have
no legal basis to prevail okay so he
doesn't need Congress for this he
doesn't and you know I I just realized
you know that there have been 58
national emergencies declared since 1976
I believe the law was passed but 79 when
they first did something and all of a
sudden the president wants to do this
we've got bet no opioids we've got human
trafficking or extra yeah humanitarian
crisis on toughest way Barack Obama can
declare a national emergency with
respect to Burundi South Sudan and the
Central African Republic this president
can certainly declare an emergency with
risk
to Mexico because you just identified
the acute imminent crisis and insofar as
drugs is concerned more than hundred
people die a day it has now doubled over
the last decade this is a serious
emergency and you know congressman
meadows I believe was just today
yesterday one of the biggest caches of
fentanyl coming across the border enough
fentanyl I don't know if people realize
our viewers realize this but if you
inhale that stuff it can take out a
state I mean just the mere presence of
it you don't have to be a drug user you
don't have to have a needle nothing the
presence of this stuff can kill off
millions of people well you're exactly
right even our law enforcement officers
many times have to wear gloves when
they're doing a search because if they
happened to have it and and get even a
small dose of this and I'm not talking
about taking it I'm just saying getting
on their skin we're inhaling it in some
way you know they they can have just
unbelievable in and fatal outcomes of
that so you know it's not just about the
drugs though and and Greg is exactly
right the president has some executive
tools in his toolbox members of Congress
we always want to restrain those but
President Barack Obama used it over and
over and over again I can tell you he
sent 1.8 billion dollars to the Iranians
I didn't appropriate that so if he can
do that certainly the president can find
a couple of billion dollars to to
support the efforts at the border 1.8
billion to the Iranians that's that's
interesting all right Greg I'm going
back to you for a second so let's assume
that this committee comes up with
nothing because they won't because
they're not meeting they're not working
they don't care right all right I say
that freely the president declares a
national emergency somebody goes to
court to stop it to get an injunction
Kamala Harris is vowing to do it all
right come on Harris is vowing to do it
which means it gets done and then it
goes to the Ninth Circuit right how
quickly can it go to the United States
Supreme Court well the president could
actually preempt at all by filing a
declaratory relief action to get an
immediate
judgment from a federal court but if he
waits for the Ninth Circuit and they
decide against him which would be wrong
by them but they always get it well then
he would seek an emergency petition to
the US Supreme Court but you know Kamala
Harris how embarrassing she was the
state attorney general in California
she says this is an abuse of power
clearly she hasn't read the law that
Congress passed giving the president the
authority and she's a member of Congress
well the amazing part of it congressman
meadows is that you know you know the
right is wrong and wrong is right and
it's almost as though we're living I'm
gonna date myself here in a twilight
zone it's like what they say is what
goes out there and they believe it even
though facts have nothing to do with it
well you're exactly right and when they
do that they forget that they voted for
border walls before or the border
fencing they forget all of that and you
know even if senator Harris thinks she's
going to file a lawsuit there's such a
thing as standing I'm not sure that any
member of Congress has standing it's
probably going to be someone else but
Greg's right there's no doubt they'll
file a lawsuit if they can they'll file
it in the Ninth Circuit but here's what
we have to understand one party is for
securing our borders and keeping our
community safe another party the
democrat party is for open borders and
saying whoever wants to come in can come
in we've got to make sure we stand up
for the rule of law judge could have
been said better a thank you both for
being on this evening